all right we are now live for another
live reading from my book
reason fulfilled by revelation this is
the first one we're getting to
this month and indeed in the new year of
2022
i'm just trying to get the lighting a
little bit better here since this is not
just
live streaming we'll be out there for a
while that's better
so um
this is indeed the first we're doing
this year we started doing these live
streaming live readings
last year and um
they've been you know
pretty well attended some good questions
coming out of them uh we're sort of
picking up in the middle right now we
are looking at
the piece by maurice blondell and shared
by a number of other
philosophers who are involved the
problem of catholic philosophy which is
chapter 7
in the work it's one of the longest
pieces
and i would say actually one of the most
important ones it's also one of the most
collaborative pieces because
blue zelda is presentation at the um
associated philosophy which is uh uh you
know not it wasn't the flagship
uh conference which would be of course
the uh
um you know based up in paris
the uh society francis di philosophy but
it was also quite important
and we're going to look today at the
letters that were
written and then responded to by two
other
philosophers slash theologian slash
historians of philosophy actually both
of these people can be called historians
of philosophy and they are ari
and joseph maraschal the jesuit
so
um
yeah let me pick up there
page
202
and we'll look at those
letters the responses
these are kind of you know heavy hitters
addressing blown down
there we go
so
comments of mr honore yang
the following notes do not bear on the
problem mr blondel has raised
they simply have for their goal
justifying the possibility of a
historical approach
number one let us renounce defending
philosophy through intellectualism
rationalism spiritualism and so on these
ism words designate a state and rigidify
an attitude they are titles to stick on
mummies intellectualization
rationalization spiritualization and as
and such fit better they evoke an
activity
they do not sacrifice the living
intelligence and the will to victory
that are the soul of all philosophy
two
philon
is a kind of work assumes a datum prior
to the work of the mind this datum is
neither rational nor intellectual or at
least cannot be said to be so
on the other hand the means by which it
is given are not necessarily
intellectual or rational or irrational
the qualification of means is also a
philosophical work the person who would
be content with everyday thought tied to
everyday life
this person would be quite indifferent
to the origin of that which is given to
them that is sensations books and even
books that are said to be inspired
three
philosophical work is an effort to
rationalize this datum whether reason
adds itself there or
rediscovers itself there does the
revealed datum resist this labor
a large part of the sensible escapes
reason must one say the revealed datum
escapes it entirely because it is
revealed
let us take a moral truth let us suppose
historically admitted that christ was
the first to preach total charity go as
far as love for one's enemies the
content of this teaching is not
irrational in any way
whether a supernatural grace would be
necessary to respond in a christian way
to christ's invitation that is a
question of a different order it still
remains the case that the intellect has
received a new and original idea of man
and that it may forget the holy
character of the text where that notion
is deposited make it enter into a
philosophy that is a synthesis where
faith ought not play any role
in the spirit of medieval philosophy mr
etienne joseon follows out the
philosophical destiny of themes arising
within the interior of the bible
and the gospels for example the i who am
in this there is no necessary
naturalization of the christian
contribution
this signifies simply that there can be
truths natural and revealed at the same
time
natural by right in this sense that
human reason can establish them
revealed in fact since a revelation has
given reason a dispensation from that
work the question is one too classical
for it to be necessary to insist upon it
there are then it seems three forms of
christian influence and by
distinguishing them we will better see
the historical approaches legitimacy
one
natural truths appear in an inspired
text and then live outside of their
context the idea of creation it seems is
of this sort
two supernatural truths presented as
such a powerful stimulants for a
philosopher's reason they allow him to
better understand the the universe
though he cannot exhaust their content
malbrasia's theory of knowledge supposes
the the fact of the fall and in that
very philosophy the fact of incarnation
is the ray of light justifying the
existence of the world
three
the philosopher considers christianity
as an experience of the divine formed
from a thousand diverse experiences he
gathers together exemplary christians
and today does not conceive of a
metaphysics that would not rest upon
their testimony such is the method mr
bergson
proposes in his latest book and here's a
footnote translator's note goulier has
in mind in here barracks owns the two
sources of morality and religion
noting the existence and the varieties
of these three influences is a
historical task that
compromises neither philosophy nor
religion the philosopher and the
religious magisterium always remain free
to critique this or that formula we do
not see what would allow them to
critique the historical method of posing
the problem they can reject this or that
philosophy that calls itself christian
they cannot deny the possibility
of a christian philosophy that is of
philosophical themes imminent to
christianity and consequently of the
historical problem concerning the
existence and the destiny of these
themes if we compare
such a project to that of mr maurice
blondel
we will see that they are too different
to rule each other out
the first will perhaps appear to be the
natural introduction to the second
all right mr blondel's response
to mr goulier
mr goulier's so precise outline takes
account already of a convergence of
views resulting from previous letters i
have exchanged with him when he had been
led to believe that my position was
contrary to the historical point of view
and would even risk in the end preparing
rationalism's triumph by affirming a
heterogeneity between the god of reason
and the god of grace i thank him for
having understood that this charge or
this suspicion remains without object he
no longer discounts my attempt and he
would like only to show that does not
cross the path he takes because this is
the labor of a historian who at first
applies himself to the christian
contribution and because this labor
seems sufficient to provide the
expression christian philosophy the
triple legitimate sense with which in
his view
it is compatible
granted he no longer prohibits me from
going beyond this but speaking truly he
does not at all examine how a further
movement is possible or legitimate nor
in what manner perhaps a doctrinal
examination
reacts on the historical perspectives he
sticks with nor
how the philosopher can for the present
or the for the future
carry out a
work of initiate initiative and
synthesis in the way of previous
speculations
would we have to believe that because of
its erudition philosophy is no more than
history of concepts and critical
analysis of the past without failing to
recognize in any way the irreplaceable
services history has rendered and still
renders to christian thought i maintain
that the three phases limiting the
horizon that's seismic
do not safeguard the current meaning and
do not lead to catholic philosophy
unless
in the very course of such movements
the philosophical problem of the
supernatural already raises itself at
least implicitly
and unless consequently this itinerary
leads us to more and more exp to more
and more explicitly raise the salutary
difficulty on which depends the
effective income
and the legitimate symbiosis of a
philosophy and a christianity each as
authentic and integral as the other
one
i am happy to hear mr goulier turning
away from mummies and all that would
freeze the activity of the philosophical
spirit into immobile and rigidified
concepts all the more reason not to
imprison living intelligence and the
sepulcher of systems and to not subject
to the forms of the past not only the
conquering activity of the present and
the future i say but what there is of
eternal vitality a metaphysical truth of
religious aspiration in what is in the
soul of doctrines where the historian
himself must seek something other than
the sediment of concepts
two
simply because philosophy would have to
draw upon a universal datum or even data
it does not result that it must submit
to them like to something that is
partially irrational or that becomes
rational only by a super added
elaboration especially when it is a
matter of nourishment or goals of the
spiritual life
speculation normally tends to render
everything it has to accept
intrinsically intelligible and to permit
its own initial passivity so as to
actively consent and cooperate
what is merely submitted to is never as
such integrated philosophically the
christian fact would not even be a fact
for philosophy if it entered into the
philosophical organism only as a raw
contribution
but it is precisely all this that will
structure the crisis in which the unique
original and irreducible character of a
catholic thought solicitus of an
intellectual submission to its true
object will either be eclipsed or shine
forth
three
starting from the notion he provides us
of the datum submitted to of which a
part remains refractory to
rationalization that is to a
an elaboration of concepts mr guide
definitively sets aside what in the
christian contribution refuses
this conceptual work
from that point on
by the very examples he offers
he confines christian speculation
insofar as according to him it accepts a
philosophical
value to what can be extracted from the
revealed bottom by and for the use of
reason an extraction that he has just
pointed out to us
accepts different modalities
but that ends up in every case in
naturalized truths
sometimes these are theses that had not
been able to be or would not have been
able to be discovered by reflection
without revelation
sometimes these are new precisions and
confirmations from which philosophical
truths that are acceptable but still
mixed up with errors or uncertainties
benefit
sometimes these are the discoveries of
the uncon of the consciousness that has
lived out some religious experience and
sees it arise in itself ideas
aspirations that seem spontaneously
human
although these products of civilization
would not have been able to appear
without christianity having been
introduced to the world
but under all these aspects which are
real and which we can in fact call
christian the problem evaporates
the specificity of the spirit of christ
has disappeared
one takes advantage of his gifts but by
bringing them back to the rational plane
and by peeling off the stamp of their
origin of their authenticity of their
demands
everything essentially transcended to
the naturally human order is
imminentized this is to strip oneself of
every means of reserving a place for the
supernatural properly called
one might as well say that from such a
point of view philosophy that is judged
to be christian by the censer is
an a christian doctrine that secularizes
the mystery of christ with this double
danger either hoarding up for modern
reason little by little all that faith
claim to contribute
or
relegating the definitively extra
philosophical element to impenetrable
obscurity without even being able as
philosophers or as historians to set any
justification forth for the use of the
term
supernatural while continuing to use the
term
in order to escape either from pure
rationalism or from a mysticism foreign
to any metaphysical and historical
grounding
such criticisms are not at all aimed at
the use of history
they aim only at the three theses
according to which either the problem
would be initially set only by the
contingent data of an external order
or the rational elaboration of these
facts would constitute the unique and
sufficient cr task of christian thought
or the religious experience of the
gospel story would disengage the ideas
included philosophically in christ's
message and would succeed in discerning
and preserving the special specifically
rational character of christianity
what is essentially a prequestion is not
partial coincidence of reason and faith
but the possibility and the obligation
to open philosophy to an order
incommensurable with it so far as we
have not seen or resolved this
difficulty historical or doctrinal
compatibilities
remain ambiguous or make us liable to
fall into an imminent naturalism without
us touching or even suspecting the
wounded point of consciousness
a salutary wound by which alone the
divine graft can be inserted into our
thought
the graph that must contribute its sap
in order for there to be new
fructification
in a more concrete manner we could
respond to the objection by saying that
the problem is that of distinguishing
and of reconnecting the god of the
metaphysicians and the crucified of
calvary the intelligible than its
necessary demands and the order of grace
and charity that doubtless is not at all
contrary or foreign but that remains
superior to the request of reason itself
while it responds to a congenital desire
and secret stimulations
christian philosophy's task consists in
prescribing the two abuses of confusing
or opposing
nature and supernature history and
doctrine
and in preparing their inviolable
distinctions as well as their legitimate
alliance
all right
comments of mr joseph marichal sj
in the recent debate about the
possibility of a catholic philosophy it
seems to me
that mr blondel has untangled the true
knot of the problem a problem before
everything else a doctrinal one one that
cannot be treated by history's methods
alone a problem already set out in
accion 1893 if it is true as victor del
bol wrote that this deep and always
current book's original thought was to
establish a philosophy that was
religious not by accident but by nature
without however being so by prejudice
a problem in principle resolved from
that time on
the same solution is represented to us
now but enriched by new precisions
no doubt that speaking in an unqualified
sense it would be acceptable it offers
nothing that philosophers must reject in
advance in the name of reason's autonomy
and nothing either i think at which the
most demanding theologians can
reasonably take umbrage
as to the very ground of the question
even if it is not exempt from difficulty
mr blondel's thesis seems to me the only
possible solution of the problem that is
perhaps not a supplementary or
accidental one
just two or three remarks on this
subject
number one
i admit at the start feeling some
repugnance at reuniting under the same
title catholic philosophy or christian
philosophy or religious philosophy
either philosophy given over to its own
means but constrained by the very
consciousness of its natural
insufficiency to reserve the place for a
hypothetical supernatural order
or supernaturally illuminated philosophy
undertaking again under the light of
faith the exploration of its own proper
domain
of these two possible states of
philosophy the second
by virtue of its alliance with revealed
faith certainly appears formally
catholic as scholastic philosophy is
still to the degree at least that in
conformity with dogma it revises and
purifies many accepted notions of
metaphysics substance person accident
etc
as will the enlarged philosophy whose
vast horizons mr blondel has us take in
but the first of these two states
the rational foundation of the second
reveals that only the free adherence of
faith would cross
reveals
remains nevertheless separated from it
by an incommensurable distance that only
the free adherence of faith would cross
it represents the end point of
philosophy plain and simple when it goes
to the extreme of its natural powers
there's nothing intrinsically or
unanimically catholic about it
does it marify this qualifier that we
give it here
just as much as mr blondel but with less
resignation perhaps i sense the
imperfection
of a two elliptical terminology
two
in relation to revealed theology
philosophy as such is incontestably
autonomous in the sense that it does not
borrow principles or primary data or a
method of demonstration from it and that
therefore if it recognizes its own
limits it must find in itself the means
for defining them also
speaking precisely autonomous philosophy
does not necessarily mean rationalist
philosophy nor even separated philosophy
the illusion of a separated philosophy
capable of buttoning itself up on its
own plane without opening problems that
exceed it still haunts many minds even
among catholic theologians
looking at it closely however these
latter impose on philosophy requests to
which a really separated philosophy
cannot do justice
i believe on my part
that a separated philosophy
leads logically either to this
methodological rationalism that in
speculative textual historical and
scientific critique imposes on itself a
rule of refusing the hypothesis of the
supernatural as unintelligible and
unassimilable to the or to that dogmatic
rationalism whose mature form in
metaphysics is always pantheism
the destroyer of the supernatural
we escape these consequences
but will this not be to fall from
carpetus into skilla if philosophy as mr
blondel rightly affirms can retain its
necessary autonomy without erecting
itself into separated philosophy
we then assume that human reason could
know itself radically and capable
according to the absolute ideal at the
ground of all reason of
bringing to perfection the system of
truths that would have legitimately
built up to a certain level
expressed in another way we suppose that
reason becomes conscious of its own
natural limits in the very consciousness
of an uncoercible but inefficacious
aspiration to exceed them here then the
problem of the supernatural formulated
in reasons
terms arises
why do so many theologians remain
mistrustful before this perspective that
should put them at ease let it be
permitted to me to extract if i dare
call it such the dialectical
quintessence of their objections
for they signal perhaps in mr blondel's
demonstration the precise point at which
he rejoins the thought of certain
classical and modern thomas a
formulation it would be useful to
reinforce
reasons
deep
affirmation aspiration for exceeding its
natural possibilities is called in
scholastic language the natural desire
for perfect and supernatural beatitude
this consisting in the immediate
intellectual possession of god
let us suppose resolve the preliminary
question raised by certain people that
are the theological acceptability of a
natural desire of the supernatural
we must understand that this desire
inefficacious in itself and objectively
conditioned by the eventuality of an
entirely free and gratuitous divine gift
does not at all possess the character of
a strict demand and allows only the pure
possibility not the existence of a
supernatural destiny to be logically
concluded
but this point established a fundamental
objection remains a natural desire for
the supernatural they say is not
something apparent and cannot be
demonstrated either
it is not apparent
a primitive inclination latent under the
operations of the soul it is only
indirectly discernible by means of these
operations it must be demonstrated the
scholastics attempted this demonstration
and saint thomas himself in the soma
contra gentiles book three see
particularly chapter five
makes it rest in the last analysis on
the law of complete universality ruling
our rational activities and thus
measuring the fundamental dynamism quote
to the absolute unlimitedness of the
formal object of our intelligence and
unlimitedness that is the condition of
thoughts logical properties corresponds
they say the unlimited scope of a
natural desire embracing and a confused
wish for intellect immediate
intellectual possession the entire
amplitude of being and consequently also
infinite being but the immediate
possession of infinite being is the
supernatural end itself this reasoning
some object ears at least in one point
the natural desire of the intellect
bears on all being all the possible but
not at all on the impossible in itself
non-being
to conclude with certainty that this
desire confusedly embraces the immediate
possession of god one would have to know
as a preliminary that this is not
something impossible in itself and how
can one know that except by the very
faith in a religious revelation
in this case i confess the friends of
the blundellian thesis seem to me to
have a lot of work to do
would saint thomas they follow up have
committed such an evident mistake of
logic let that not stand a great number
of thomas down through the centuries c
in the soma contra gentiles
argumentation not the proof of the
possibility of the supernatural by the
means of natural desire of the vision of
god but only
the proof that under the implicitly
admitted hypothesis
of a supernatural order of salvation the
deep desire
of the intellect does not have a
saturating endpoint prior
or inferior to the vision of god
despite the ingeniousness with which
this interpretation has been many times
defended the text of the summa contra
gentiles it seems to me
resists here and in everything essential
renders correct the reverend father de
broglie's exegesis by which mr blondel
authorizes himself but i cannot linger
here over that debate
what has to be conceded to the objection
is that st thomas's demonstration if it
must remain free of all theological
presupposition depends on two
general principles of which the second
under its abstract form perhaps does not
possess the same degree of evidence as
the first for number one every faculty
tries to equal by its operations the
extensive fullness of its formal
object every to every faculty aims
vis-a-vis what sort of object at the
perfect mode of its operation
but the perfect operation of the
intellect is direct
or even intuitive apprehension of its
objects secundum eorum substantium says
saint thomas let an object be indirectly
signified to our intellect for example
the creator and creatures and the
intellect will naturally necessarily
desire by necessity of nature to know it
in itself directly it is here that an
objection will drop short by necessity
of nature how can we know that so long
as a doubt still remains about the
intrinsic possibility of the claim to be
desired knowledge the perfect mode the
object of the natural desire is only the
most perfect mode that the constitution
of the faculty and the constitution of
the object tolerate
nevertheless i believe that saint thomas
and the soma contra gentiles not only
wanted to produce a strictly rational
proof but also correctly constant
constructed it the critical remarks i
have just related deform it somewhat by
reducing it entirely to the type of
formal analytical deduction proceeding
by a simple partitioning of concepts
under the light of abstract principles
perhaps under this aspect saint thomas's
proof is not peremptory it regains its
advantage understood before everything
else as a concrete exploration of the
life of the mind a true interior
experiment where a primitive functional
necessity expresses itself in exercise
directing every intellectual act
whatever its content may be
and in fact understood in this way this
on some contradictions text allows it
it would be most in harmony with the
dialectic rational and concrete at the
same time animating a similar proof in
the book oxio 1893
still if one will permit me one last
operia deprived of practical interest i
admit
should we not then address the st thomas
himself the question set recently to mr
blondel
a concrete dialectic that discovers in
us the confused natural desire for
something beyond nature does this
explore an essential disposition of the
human intellect or rather some
disposition created in the intellect by
the contingent fact of humanity's
primitive vocation to supernatural life
in the first case
this dialectic really grounds a
philosophy in the ordinary sense of the
word in the second case no
because
it presupposes a supernatural fact to
know which of these cases we are in
reason does not possess any decisive
criteria other than the following the
latent desire for divine intuition is it
or is it not the necessary intrinsic
condition of all our intellectual
activities so that to deny it brings us
back to denying the intellect itself by
suppressing the root of the possibility
of knowing and willing
in the affirmative answer we have not
left the field of philosophy but this
regressive proof of natural desire a
sort of transcendental deduction
demanded by appointed critique is
provided to us i believe among other
riches in the pages of oxyo 1893
but not explicitly in the soma country
gentiles
by supplying it mr blondel responds in
advance to the difficulty that he
himself recounted in his presentation
for if the primitive dynamic orientation
of natural reason already designates as
the hypothetical endpoint of an
inefficacious desire the very end point
towards which the supernatural activity
rooted in this dynamism strives
no ambiguity remains as to the identity
of the absolute summit and asymptote for
reason the true end for faith but of
course we would have to make this
solution in principle valid in the
details
mr blondel's response to mr joseph
maraschal sj
the reverend father marshall professor
of the school of philosophical sciences
of leuven of a competence and
penetration universally admired in the
field of speculative theology brings to
us a contribution of exceptional value
for which we are deeply grateful
adhering to the majority of his analyses
and his conclusions which i would like
to comment on at length i must to my
regret confine myself here to several
brief reflections
one
the reverend father entirely rightly
signify signals the multiversity of the
expression christian or catholic
philosophy in the third part of the
cayenne
20 of the nouvelle journey i had
spontaneously indicated the three stages
where philosophy can provisionally halt
but to which it must ultimately climb
philosophy that begins by being a
complete and comprehensive metaphysics
relative to necessary virtualities of
any created mind with its congenital
aspirations and its limitations which do
not hinder the infinite perspectives of
thought and willing
philosophy that then continues by a
study of positive deficiencies of
dispositions that result from them of
real obligations deriving from the
historical or concrete state in which
man has been constituted has fallen is
called again
philosophy finally that must take
account of all those auxilia externa at
interna whether they be subconscious or
unnamed
without for those reasons ceasing to
possess a psychological and dynamic
reality
but the name befitting each of these
stages is not equally christian and i
have noted that if one uses it even for
the first it is because the light of
christianity alone
has actually allowed the rectilinear and
unrestricted attitude of rational
doctrine compatible with all the
requirements and nothing but the
requirements of faith to be rendered
exact
the litigious qualifier is all the more
justified for the higher stages since
they concern not only rational
necessities and metaphysical foundations
of faith but also realities that
gratuitous gifts and the divine vocation
incarnate
even if i have preferred the singular
designation catholic philosophy
it was in order to cause to re-emerge at
the same time the universalist character
and the purity of the properly
supernatural element that this endpoint
implies and that if we reflect on this
in a fundamental way alone renders
conceivable and viable the both rational
rational and religious doctrine whose
proper designation we are
seeking
two the reverend father mara shall
offers us a model of erudite and steel
sharp disgust discussion illuminating by
its dialectical precision and
comprehensive in its good will since he
has so generously shed light on my
intentions on the very goal
of my work
i will not follow his track step by step
where i would have only to proceed along
the path i myself took i will confine
myself therefore to two or three
complementary
glosses even if we place ourselves at
the start or if we try to remain within
the domain of abstract analyses of the
nature of faculties and the perfection
of their exercise in light of their
object it seems to me we must remove
certain inconsistent and even mutilating
objections
yes or no does reason know and even
demonstrate normally and with certainty
that god is yes or no do we legitimately
and with a rational necessity affirm
that god is one infinite the principle
of intelligibility and reality the
supreme end and that at the same time he
incommensurably exceeds our knowledge
and range of our grasps
yes or no knowing that god is truth
goodness beatitude can we not attempt to
glimpse more of him to desire something
of his beauty and his felicity well we
still realizing his secret belongs to
him that its possession does not depend
on us that reasonably we cannot we
cannot claim to attain it and conquer it
without our ceasing to experience a
spontaneous nostalgia that the most
generous labor of reflection of science
of human virtue only
makes wax stronger become more exact and
exalted
if this is so
how can we not affirm that such an
aspiration and such a nostalgia are not
congenital and constitutive in every
spiritual creature how can we not
recognize that no intellectual and moral
consciousness is possible and real even
in subordinate applications
without this intimate and supreme spring
will we say that philosophy can confine
itself to what has been called the god
of the philosophers close itself up in a
concept and fix an immobile doctrine
that would be philosophy itself perfect
and sufficient without restlessness and
without religious expectation
but would we have thus to divide god
into two slices one that reason could
grasp and devour and then one that would
be super metaphysical in its mystery
juxtaposed to the zone of absolute
clarity there seems to me something
unintelligible in the hypothesis of this
slicing up
uh
that the unbridgeable separation of
natural theology and the god of
tradition and one must say the god of
conscience entails
the very idea of a philosophy in itself
does it not contradict the etymology the
reality the life of this word and of
this so human thing that results from
all of our being penetrated by the sur
sum of reason towards infinity
thus even from the abstract and
conceptual point of view there is in
fact a necessary and metaphysical
question that imposes itself on the most
developed philosophy according to
cardinal deschamps expression and to
take advantage of a suggestion of the
reverend father mara shaw that offers a
sort of alternative i add that far from
opting between two endpoints we must
hold two solutions at the same time
on the one hand from the ground of
intelligible nature arises the
uncoercible and inefficacious movement
that expresses itself by indeterminate
desire of vision and beatitude and this
already derives essentially from
philosophical speculation
on the other hand in humanity's concrete
and historical state the positive
calling and the interior or exterior
stimulations rendering it obligatory
decisive and accessible are added to
this order of necessary possibility
philosophy which does not terminate in
concepts
but which bases itself on realities of
nature of human experience and history
also can and must take account of this
concept in the integration of the
doctrine that rightly claims to neglect
none of the data of the problem to
resolve
but in order to productively take
account of all the concrete data without
confusion and without presumption it
would be necessary for philosophical
science as a preliminary to go through
the critical and metaphysical phase that
alone prevents any hybridization of
natural powers and supernatural gifts
whose differentiation compatibility and
cooperation catholic philosophy must
secure
by those reconnecting the two paths that
the reverend father mara shall has shown
us to be legitimate and complementary i
hope to enter into his views by adding
that these paths are solidary and
subordinate
against those who limit christian
speculation to the historicity of the
factual data or against those who no
longer partisans of a sort of
historicism but of what might call a
historism would like to seek in the
profound history of souls the human
elements of a religious synthesis i give
him infinite thanks for having indicated
that the problem to raise
necessarily implies a metaphysical
aspect and a determination of the notion
of the supernatural at the intersection
of rational demands historical data and
intimate experiences
none of these elements sufficing by
itself speculatively
or practically
so that takes us up to the discussion
that will then happen between maurice
blondel jacques paliart and gaston
bergere which we will read and talk
about next time and then we're we're
getting to part three of the book so um
everybody's weighing in at the start
saying hello so hello to everybody so
masak is he so i'm not sure which he
you're referring to because we've got
three different people here
claiming that all metaphysical
revelation of god
and that is similar to the concept of
multiplicity of bergstone absolutely not
those have zero connection at all
multiplicity in bergson i mean if you
look at the essay on the immediate
givens of consciousness translated as
time and free will
multiplicity just means multiplicity
right and
it doesn't have any religious
connotations at all it has metaphysical
connotations um you know one of the
points bergstone is making from the very
beginning is that time understood as
sort of linear cut up time
and language
understood in certain ways and
spatiality is not adequate to our
experience which is indeed of
multiplicity but these these are these
have no connections to each other
whatsoever and i would suggest if you
want to understand these these thinkers
stick with the people that they're
actually talking about so you know
thomas was referenced in this you know
it can't hurt to look at the soma contra
gentiles that's being discussed there um
bergson as i mentioned much much earlier
when i was doing the introduction did
not take part in these debates
um he had a follower edward lerwa who
played an incredibly marginal part in
the very first part of the debates but
the bergsonians were not really
involved in when you read the um uh
the work that's that's actually
mentioned
um it it's kind of hit or miss you know
the two sources of morality and religion
could have been an entry into these
debates and it wasn't bergstone wasn't
wasn't really attuned to these things
uh another one from mossack is he
claiming that all metaphysical relation
of god are valid nobody's ever claimed
that all metaphysical revelations
claimed as revelations of god are valid
so
that's kind of a non-starter you're not
going to find that among any
philosophers of religion and you're not
going to find that among
religious practitioners that's why some
people say well your visions are
[ __ ] our visions are good so that
one's kind of a non-starter way to
approach this stuff what i will say is
that when it comes to
thinking about revelations these people
are
extraordinarily careful with it they're
not like well god said to me in a dream
last night blah blah blah blah so
therefore i need to incorporate that
into philosophy they're like well how do
you know it was god in the first place
and let's think about the meaning of
what's actually being said here and
let's uh bring some tools to bear on it
we don't want to like be prejudiced
against it and say well
there can't be any revelation be like a
human about miracles or something like
that
but one thing that is you know running
throughout these debates is an
incredible sophisticated attitude
towards these these sorts of ideas uh
coming in and and being willing to say
listen uh
revealed truths they have to be
integrated they can't just be like plunk
down and be the deciding factor so
that would be where you actually you
know you want to go back and get your
hands on a copy of the text and read
what jill sean wrote and read what
blondel wrote and read with some of the
other thinkers that we've read up to
this time
have said
so mark says um
[Music]
could you perhaps speak a bit more about
the relationship between terria and the
beatific vision so
um
yeah i mean
they're referencing a discussion that
actually took place in the earlier part
of the 20th century before these 1930s
debates
um you hear them mentioning the term
gita broglie right so gita broglie was a
christian author
um very interested in in unpacking this
natural desire for the supernatural
which
we do find thomas referencing and
because thomas referenced it and because
so many philosophers were at least in
theory thomas you kind of couldn't get
away from it right and this was to
this is a great thing to respond to
people who want to say you've got a
natural order and a supernatural order
and they're sort of like oil and water
one is on top of the other they don't
mix whether they're rationalists or like
this supernatural order is all imaginary
[ __ ] or whether they're the
neo-scholastics who are like these got
to be really you know rigidly
distinguished philosophies down here
theologies up here or the fetus or like
the philosophy part that's all crap get
rid of it right these are the basic uh
categories that uh at angel sol laid out
in his contribution again very early in
in this work
um
if there is something like a natural
desire for the supernatural that is
that is inarticulate
but which we cannot really escape from
and it's not just a metaphysical thing
like the need for being or something
like that and it's not a purely
psychological thing like the need to
belong to groups
but something something that really does
tap into the transcendent and something
that can be refined
then that can be um
[Music]
sort of like a what husserl in his time
called a light and font and a leading
clue something that orients our inquiry
and this fits in very well with
blondel's own view that a
uh one thing that would be necessary in
order to have a genuinely christian
philosophy is that it be what we call a
philosophy of insufficiency that that
can
figure out where philosophy itself does
not meet up to its own
desires its own norms and where there
are
he had different names for this empty
spaces
voids lacunae within it that are yet to
be
filled and they can only be filled if
they're actually recognized as being
there they're not paved over
and and hidden so um
i don't know if that's if that's fully
answering uh the issue but
let me take up uh these others from
masakri um
is marshall's concept of agnostic
philosophical foundation
similar to heidegger's option that
philosophy should be atheistic and god
will later fit into the picture i don't
think so um again i wouldn't try to
bring in other people to to do
comparison and contrast here i think
that's going to be misleading you
and probably not very helpful at all you
want to take these people on in in their
own
um
on their own um
view
um i mean we could talk about heidegger
here heidegger's conception of
philosophy is found in phenomenological
interpretations of aristotle heidegger's
conception of philosophy is found in
many works of heidegger
and i would not rest very much just on
one single
work like that
that that strikes me as a recipe for
going wrong and understanding heidegger
but heidegger is not really relevant
here um
you know
and
uh mara shall
is not saying that we have to have a
completely agnostic philosophical
foundation
he's saying there's a lot of moving
parts to this right
so
um one of the things that i particularly
like with these two arne guilier is a
very very important french historian of
philosophy
who was attuned to these debates and you
know like he mentions you know he had
some correspondence with blondel about
them he also he was one of these figures
who could recognize that some of the key
positions in the debates like that of
jill saw and mauritan on one side and
that of maurice blondel on another
and you know um gabriel marcel and some
of the other people involved were
actually compatible and and complemented
each other something that blondel and
jill so and
mara 10 were unwilling to recognize
they they were a little bit too
polemical towards each other
so goulier is really good on that mara
shaw i'll mention too by the way
brilliant brilliant thinker
never got to teach graduate students i'm
not sure what it was about the jesuits
where they decided to kind of screw him
around that way but he wrote a lot of
really great historical studies of
philosophy
for the
young
you know seminarians that he was
teaching
um
it's it's kind of a it's kind of a sad
story in some ways
um all right mark to expand on my
question
uh it seems to that aristotle's concept
ethereal presents something like
the
fulfills but limited to reason longs for
the divine but never actually reaches it
well in a christian concept the beatific
vision
fulfills but transcends reason and
offers a more satisfactory possibility
yeah i would say it's not that simple um
i would say aristotle's concept of
terria already includes a certain kind
of the divine because what do we
contemplate well the things that don't
really change like the heavens and i
mean we can actually also have teoria
of human affairs like well what is the
politics that's also terraria or you
know
using the mind in in that particular
modality that's not directly practical
despite aristotle saying oh we're
studying this to be practical [ __ ]
there's also
you know it's clear that aristotle's
interested in this stuff for the sake of
knowing it and you know he doesn't talk
that much about the divine in most of
the books that we tend to read but you
know there there are
discussions uh enough where
uh there's there's speculation about
just how many divine objects are there
in aristotle so aristotle does have a
conception of the divine here's where we
get to something interesting so there
are multiple conceptions of the divine
and one of the very things that
christianity i would say puts on the
table and doesn't do so just by saying
boom there's revelation man go go to
work on it but rather in a sort of
cumulative dialectical process is the
nature of the divine
you know and a lot of that is building
off of stuff that's there
in the jewish scriptures and traditions
but also there is clement of alexandria
recognized in
ancient greek and roman philosophy and
in other things as as well
so yeah
the beatific vision
is just one thing that
transcends reason um you know if you
look at
anselm of canterbury he's not asking for
the beatific vision he's asking for
understanding right phoenix quadrants
intellectual faith-seeking understanding
and that is going to be an understanding
that is sort of like you know to use
blondel's wonderful
metaphor of the graft there's there's a
wound
a a cut an opening and the divine comes
in and grafts itself in there and
there's an a mixture where it's no
longer so easy to say here's where the
divine ends and here's where the purely
human
begins
uh daniel what was the influence of this
debate on the vatican council there was
no influence of this debate on the
vatican council there was influence of
some of the thinkers involved in the
debate on the second vatican council for
example maurice blondell is often called
the philosopher of vatican ii right and
why is he called so because um
through people like mara shall
transcendental thomas he influenced the
debate you know their influence on
people like carl rauner
and
his massive influence along with others
like you know uh charles p
and uh other people on the nouvelle
theology two different strands that
flowed into the second vatican council
but there's no direct line between this
fate the second vatican council
it's much more like this
same people have some involvements in it
this is an interesting
way of talking about things
aquinas seems to plug something of a gap
in aristotle so that's a pretty blown
alien way of looking at it
rather than like
you know
you know aristotle understood the
complete natural order this is the
[ __ ] scholastic way of looking at
things or the the crappy history of
philosophy of looking at things so we
had aristotle and he was like the
brilliant the philosopher and understood
the natural order and then you know we
had aquinas who came in around you know
the the 13th century and managed to you
know take aristotle's ideas and the
christian bible and bring them and all
you got to do is like read a couple
pages of aquinas and and you realize
that that's totally not not how things
work aquinas was somebody who read
voraciously uh across
uh you know a whole bunch of different
philosophical and christian traditions
and who tries to synthesize and
incorporate in a dialectical manner all
of these things and yeah there's there's
places where i mean there's there's gaps
in aristotle even from the perspective
of the non-christian
aristotelian
commentators in antiquity where they're
like
wish aristotle would have said more
about this so that's why i'm going to
say more about this right
i think about alexander of aphrodisias
who is if aristotle is the philosopher
alexander is called the commenter right
blondel
said this is going to be the case this
is naturally the case for philosophy
every philosophy is full of holes empty
spaces
lacunae this is a natural part of
philosophical work there's holes in
thomas aquinas's own views and that's
you know i mean who knows what he saw in
his his vision towards the end of his
life when he gave up uh writing the
somatiologia and quit the commentary on
the psalms at
number 54 which is unfinished a psalm
commentary that i've translated
but part of it could have been a
realization of the inadequacy the
insufficiency of the philosophy that he
had
generated
um
all right
abdulrasheed
greetings from somalia you like the
videos that's very nice to read
and i will keep doing that mark says i
want to say i can't attest to the
original
french but to my ear your translations
are a pleasure to listen to you've
conveyed these debates with a lot of
life thank you yeah and you know it's
kind of funny so
that this is the product
of a pan greg
a greg from
20 to
10 years ago
um a greg who was in his 30s and
published this
when he was 40 not even 41.
um i'm now 50 and
when i read it i am
except when i see a typo or something
like that i'm i'm pretty happy with the
renditions as well now a lot of that um
is to the credit of the writers
themselves
and some of them are a pleasure to read
in the french some of them are less of a
pleasure for their style until you get
you blondel is one of those guys man he
can be tough to read like hegel or like
cicero
cicero and the original not so much
cicero in english um
and
you know some some of them like at
angels or just great writers um
brahir was was too
uh certian i would say is and so i think
that's part of what comes through
some of them there's not much you can do
to fix it like john devil vays french
you're like what in the hell is this
what's this guy saying
so you just try to you just try to make
it make it work um so you know a lot of
it is it's due to the source material
it's sort of like being a musician who
plays other people's music if the music
they wrote is good okay you're gonna
sound pretty good if what they wrote is
just kind of trite and you know boring
well you're gonna you're gonna be kind
of boring
um
zeno currently reading a textbook from
my ethics class talking about
consequentialism in the beginning yeah
okay that's that's great um i don't know
that that has anything to do with this
but um
that's pretty common
uh devonnie the relationship between
reason and revelation seems so vital for
our understanding of the world what
could be done a good question
what could be done to make this more
central to our humanities education
today wow that's that's a
great question
um
so i'll just say two things one is it
would actually have to be like
thematically introduced by people who
know what they're talking about and
aren't just
taking easy solutions or stuff like that
and uh that's that's that's a tough sell
you know
you we don't even have philosophy
classes in our k through 12 education
unless you
go to a religious school in which case
it might be not very good philosophy or
it might be decent philosophy
taught usually as a religion object but
not objective and and elective
or if you're lucky enough to go to a
rich public school that is well funded
and um can offer a philosophy class as a
english or a
social studies elective right
so that is good oh the time is really
going i i have an appointment at the top
of the hour so i'm gonna have to wrap
this up and
and get going um
[Music]
i'll take this last question from massac
while translating your work did your
conception of the divine philosophy
theology change or was it fixed and
crystallized from the beginning neither
because
my views are kind of a hybrid of a lot
of different things lots of moving parts
and so are many of the people involved
in these these debates as well so
all right i'm going to bring this to a
close uh it's been a nice hour to pass
with all of you and uh normally i'd
stick around more but i've got a i got
an appointment with somebody to talk
about death
so i will see all of you we're going to
do this again next week i'll see you see
you then